German tobacco. Last one. Too bad.
I know how you feel.
The same thing happened to me.
You visit Germany, yes? Dessau.
You must be Sherlock Holmes.
You are an engineer.
You read German magazines.
Magazines about airplanes.
All Japanese engineers visit Dessau.
You're exactly right.
-Dr. Junkers is in trouble.
-What kind of trouble?
He fights the government. He will blow up.
Mr. Hitler's government?
The Nazis are a gang of hoodlums.
This is a good place.
No mosquitoes. Not hot. Good watercress.
A good place to forget bad things.
Cigarette? I'm afraid they're Japanese.
Thank you.
It is a nice night.
"Hier ist der Zauberberg."
"The Magic Mountain." By Thomas Mann?
A good place for forgetting.
Make a war in China. Forget it.
Make a puppet state
in Manchuria. Forget it.
Quit the League of Nations. Forget it.
Make the world your enemy. Forget it.
Japan will blow up.
Germany will blow up too.
-Will Germany go to war again?
-Yes. They must be stopped.